inside the borderline Bar and Grille
gunman has opened fire and after a pause
starts shooting again people have dived
for cover and take their chances running
for safety at a vigil for the victims
last night we met someone who escaped
that shooting alive
but saw three of her friends die in the
massacre
yeah they run tests because even tests
don't do anything because this guy was
messed up in the head and he was still
able in period go would you like the
politicians to do step up and do
something instead of just all this talk
everyone's just all talk no one's action
we need do something about Alexis his
friends had survived another mass
shooting in Las Vegas last year only to
be caught up and killed in this one
earlier news cameras had heard from one
of their mothers my son was tell her
fanos we lost him last night at the
borderline shooting my son was in Las
Vegas with a lot of his friends and he
came home he didn't come home last night
and I don't want prayers
I don't want thoughts I want gun control
and I hope to god nobody else sends me
any more prayers I want gun control no
more guns
thank you a police officer also lost his
life crowds lined the route as sergeant
ron helis his body was moved
julie novak trained with him and knew
him well tell us how you what went
through your your mind how did you react
this today when you when you heard what
happened to him
first of all shocked shocked that this
could happen here and shocked that this
happened Iran and then like just knowing
yeah of course he was the guy first on
scene of course he was the guy that
risked his life to save everybody else's
just of course he was a hero because
that was him
Thousand Oaks was declared the third
safest city in America this year a leafy
well-heeled suburb like so many other
scenes of mass shootings in America it's
less than two weeks since eleven people
were killed by a gunman on the other
side of the country in Pittsburgh you
might say this is the last place you'd
expect this to happen in America except
that is no longer true in a country
where mass shootings are so common and
increasingly frequent that it seems
nowhere is safe and yet despite all that
this is a country still paralyzed by
failure to find a way to stop these
massacres happening over and over again
Domenic Waghorn Sky News Thousand Oaks
California